[Musik]
hätte er heute live ganz herzlich
willkommen lässt sich die notlage
schaffen dass unsere frage am heutigen
abend und natürlich sind damit gemeint
die intensivstationen die sich ja immer
noch füllen die mit immer mehr corona
patienten zu kämpfen haben mit einer
immer größeren belastung bis hin zu den
grenzen dieser belastung bis hin zur
überlastung und noch immer und wohl noch
eine ganze weile werden intensiv
patienten in andere bundesländer verlegt
was kann man dagegen tun und wie ist der
alltag auf den stationen im moment
darüber sprechen wir in wenigen minuten
mit dr christoph spinner pandemie
beauftragter am klinikum rechts der isar
in münchen und zuvor und gleich zu
beginn mit carsten schmidt er ist
intensivpfleger und stationsleiter am
klinikum saarbrücken herzlich willkommen
herr schmidt und einen schönen guten
abend
hallo herr schmidt wie ist die lage
aktuell auf ihrer station
ja also wir haben schon ordentlich zu
tun kann man so ganz plump sagen also
wir haben eine zusätzliche corona
intensivstation eröffnen müssen weil wir
doch eine erhebliche anzahl an kroner
patienten mittlerweile bei uns liegen
haben und haben hierzu auch natürlich
noch ganz andere patienten spricht nach
einem herzinfarkt oder nach einem
schweren verkehrsunfall und ja also es
ist
es brennt schon an vielen stellen der
baum das kann man ruhig so deutlich
sagen müssen sie da jetzt schon
sozusagen also das wort trial geistert
immer so ein bisschen durch den raum
müssen sie jetzt schon entscheidungen
treffen die hart sind
das ist eine frage dass sollten da
müssen andere darüber entscheiden wir
von unserer pflegerischen seite wir
versorgen alles an patienten was kommt
und
geben unser bestes und sind so
professionell wie eh und je das will ich
gar nicht in frage stellen bevor wir
weiter über die situation bei ihnen an
der klinik sprechen wollen wir uns noch
mal ein ganz allgemeinen überblick
verschaffen über das was momentan in
deutschland das ist ja nicht nur ein
einzelfall dieses krankenhaus sondern es
gibt ja mehrere wo die situation fast
identisch ist über die situation in
deutschland die ziemlich ernstes michael
feller bioland
die vierte corona welle sie bringen
deutschlands intensivstationen zusehend
in bedrängnis
4797 menschen liegen dort derzeit wegen
co wird 19 tendenz steigend es sind
ähnliche werte wie in der letzten welle
am 27 april 20 21 waren es 5000 64
kobelt intensivpatienten
die meisten von ihnen sind zwischen 60
und 69 jahre alt aber auch menschen in
den vierzigern machen rund zehn prozent
aus
die behandlung von koma patienten ist
besonders aufwendig das bedeutet auch
ein enormer druck für pfleger und
pflegerinnen
zur entlastung der kliniken können
corona patienten verlegt werden und zwar
nach dem kleeblatt konzept deutschland
ist dafür in fünf regionen unterteilt
wenn im eigenen verbund kein platz mehr
ist ihm die anderen auf eine extreme
situation und es könnte noch schlimmer
kommen
gesundheitsminister sparen zeichnete ein
düsteres bild der korona lage
deutschland wird die zahl von über 5.000
19 patienten auf den intensivstationen
deutlich noch in den nächsten tagen
wochen übersteigen die lage auf den
intensivstationen wird also wenn die
maßnahmen greifen rund um weihnachten
ihren traurigen höhepunkt erreichen
also den traurigen höhepunkt werden wir
noch erreichen sagt der noch amtierende
gesundheitsminister an der stelle
vielleicht auch noch mal der hinweis an
euch liebe userinnen und user gerne
natürlich fragen und kommentare über die
bekannten kanäle an uns schicken wir
haben gerade wie gesagt sie hat spar
noch mal gehört also der traurige
höhepunkt um weihnachten herum das sind
ja keine besonders besinnlichen
aussichten wie geht es ihnen als pfleger
wenn sie wenn sie das hören
ja das ist natürlich erschreckend weil
das problem dass jetzt auf uns wartet
oder der herausforderung hätte
eigentlich vermieden werden können mit
den impfungen und ja wir rechnen auch
damit dass das keine besinnliche
weihnachtszeit wird sondern schon eine
actionreiche und auch nicht nur bis
weihnachten sondern auch noch über das
jahr hinaus und das ist für uns alle
schon sehr frustrierend weil wir das
jetzt seit über zwei knapp zwei jahren
mitmachen und natürlich wie gesagt es
hätte eine lösung gegeben für das
problem welche lösungen es gab noch mal
sagen
die lösung wäre das impfen ist zeigen
die zahlen ja ganz deutlich und das
spürt denke ich jeder in der
gesellschaft das nur dass die lösung ist
die uns weiterbringt und halt etwas
vernunft auch im alltag was kontakte
angeht damit wir uns allen auf den
intensivstationen egal wo in deutschland
oder auch weltweit geholfen ja also
immer wieder dass impfen man kann es gar
nicht oft genug wiederholen im beitrag
ist ja gerade auch das kleeblatt system
also die verteilung von
intensivpatienten innerhalb deutschlands
angesprochen worden welche erfahrungen
haben sie damit bislang gemacht sie
haben ja auch schon patienten
aufgenommen so weit ich weiß
ja also ich sehe dieses system sehr
positiv ich finde es auch
selbstverständlich dass man sich unter
den bundesländern oder auch
länderübergreifend eben hilft ich denke
das ist alternativlos jeder von uns
würde die die hilfe auch wollen wenn es
jetzt im saarland höhere zahlen geben
würde wie in sachsen werden wir auch
froh wenn die uns helfen würden von
daher sehe ich das als
selbstverständlich an er hat also immer
gerade noch einmal bilder auch von ihrer
station und man sieht natürlich auch was
das für ein immenser aufwand ist er da
betrieben werden muss darauf kommen wir
dann später noch zu sprechen
das kleeblatt system hatten wir gerade
sie haben es natürlich auch nach wie vor
mit vielen ungeimpften patienten zu tun
einer von diesen ungeimpften hat sich
auch bei uns vor der kamera geäußert und
da wollen wir noch mal kurz reinhören
internet halt auch recherchiert
dass alles fehlinformationen es stimmt
zum trost hat stimmt das alles gerne und
sie haben es trotzdem glaubt
klartext ihm geglaubt warum
ja weil ich wie gesagt ich war relativ
sicher sage ich das selber netz
befördert
er hat auf das internet sagt er vertraut
hat aber inzwischen eingesehen und zwar
leidvoll eingesehen dass das offenbar
eine fehleinschätzung war der er da
unterlegen ist bei der entscheidung sich
nicht impfen zu lassen wir sprechen
gleich weiter ich will vielleicht noch
den einen oder anderen kommentar auch an
der stelle folge sind oft schwer
schreibt uns über youtube ein kleines
beispiel mein schwager arbeitet auf der
intensivstation es wurden vier betten
abgebaut von 14 betten warum kein
personal nur drei leute verfügbar da von
einer für ganztagsbetreuung bleiben noch
zwei für die restlichen 10 also der
lässt sich schon sehen der
personalschlüssel äußerst schwierig
welche erfahrungen haben sie mit der
personalsituation bei ihnen an der
klinik gemacht
ja man muss ja sagen das problem
personalmangel in der pflege besteht ja
schon vor corona also seit jahren oder
jahrzehnten hätten wir ja schon förmlich
um hilfe aus der politik um den
personalmangel entgegenzusteuern und
corona bringt es jetzt einfach nur mehr
ans tageslicht und es ist in aller munde
daher ist das thema für uns nichts neues
und ja
wir haben die hoffnung auf besserung und
hilfe von der politik eigentlich nahezu
schon begraben sind natürlich traurige
worte wenn man das so hört ich wie
gesagt will da auch gerne noch mal näher
darauf eingehen aber vielleicht vorher
noch kurz die wortmeldung von en 54
power über youtube betten haben wir
genug ist fehlt personal wenn 9000
betten in einer pandemie abgebaut werden
dann läuft grundsätzlich etwas falsch
dem kann man sich sicherlich
anschließend aber weil wir gerade auch
nochmal den patienten gehört haben der
umgebung zwar das ist auch ein punkt den
ich gerne noch kurz mit ihnen besprechen
würde er hat immerhin jetzt eine
fehleinschätzung eingeräumt
andere sehen das ja offenbar noch nicht
so wie ist das wenn sie mit solchen
leuten zu tun haben sind sie da immer
noch genauso motiviert wie vor einem
jahr oder wie groß ist ihre persönliche
frustration auch im umgang mit menschen
die eben nicht geimpft sind
natürlich wir sind alle frustriert aber
das hat nicht gezielt mit den einzelnen
patienten hier zu tun sondern aus dem
gesamten gesellschaftlichen bild das
einfach entstanden ist
wir behandeln alle patienten
professionell und alle haben eine
ordnungsgemäße versorgung verdient aber
natürlich wissen wir auch und sehen auch
dass das uns zusätzlich belastet und wir
reden da im team darüber aber die
patienten versorgen wir trotzdem so gut
wie eben können er spricht absolut für
sie sprechen sie denn mit ungeimpften
was was sagen die ihnen was sind die
gründe für ihr verhalten welchen
eindruck haben sie da und sind die
überhaupt auch vielleicht ihren
argumenten zugänglich
ja ich glaube ein großes problem ist
einfach die aufklärung die aufklärung in
deutschland ist meiner meinung nach sehr
schlecht was die komplette pandemie
angeht da hätte man schon von anbeginn
an dann ganz anders agieren müssen sei
es aufklärung was das thema hygiene
händehygiene oder abstand und mundschutz
angeht ungenau sodass auch mit der
impfung man muss sich einfach zu sehr
gezielt irgendwo informieren um über die
impfung informiert zu sein und man muss
einfach die breite der gesellschaft
anders erreichen dass übers fernsehen
oder über verschiedene andere kanäle
gibt sicherlich wege die leichter sind
um in eine breitere masse aufzuklären
und das würde sicherlich helfen ja das
können wir uns natürlich auch ans revers
heften immerhin heute abend denke ich
leisten wir wieder ein beitrag um leute
aufzuklären oder gibt es ja kaum was
besseres als eben mit leuten wie ihnen
aus der praxis zu sprechen und die eben
dann auch nochmal appellieren zum
beispiel sich impfen zu lassen sie
schildern auch den umgang und die
alltagssituation sehr eindrücklich denen
sie ausgesetzt sind in einem online zu
lesen tagebuch das ganze findet sich
unter www klinikum saarbrücken de das
würde ich ihnen gerne auch noch mal
zeigen bzw euch also hier sehen wir dass
das corona tagebuch die vierte corona
welle zum beispiel so da gibt es
verschiedene kapitel und das ist auch
chronologisch sozusagen
ordnet und da schreiben sie sehr
ausführlich und sehr anschaulich über
verschiedene probleme mit denen sie
beschäftigt sind unter anderem geht es
auch darum welche enorme aufwand
betrieben werden muss um die intensiv
patienten zu betreuen wir uns ja gerade
auch schon in den bildern gesehen das
ist bis zu fünf personen teilweise
braucht um patienten zum beispiel
zuwenden wie wahnsinnig ist heiß wird
auch unter der schutzausrüstung und wie
oft sie sich umziehen müssen wenn sie
das alles so niederschreiben diese
ganzen probleme die sie da haben
zweifeln sie manchmal an ihrer
berufswahl oder sagen sie trotzdem war
genau der richtige job für mich und ist
es nach wie vor
der job das werden ihnen glaube ich also
weil das kind alle kollegen bestätigen
ist ist ein schöner beruf er wurde halt
aber über jahre kaputt gespart und
kaputtgemacht dahingehend auch und das
ist das problem der eigentliche beruf
ist schön aber es hat halt eben am
personalmangel und die zeit den die wir
gerne für die patienten aufbringen
würden haben wir einfach nicht und das
ist einer der elementaren punkte der
sich der sich einfach ändern muss als
mit eines der reichsten länder in europa
sollte das für deutschland doch
irgendwie machbar sein ja ich will noch
mal darauf hinweisen www klinikum
saarbrücken de dort findet sich das
corona tagebuch von ihnen und ich finde
das wirklich sehr eindrücklich zu lesen
und man bekommt nochmal ein ganz anderes
verständnis dafür welche probleme und
welche nöte tatsächlich auf diesen
stationen vorherrschen profi nato
schreibt uns bzw bafin hatte official so
sein name was wünscht sich herr schmidt
von der politik und den menschen da
draußen sie haben gerade schon gesagt
von der politik wünschen sie sich gar
nicht mehr so viel vielleicht können wir
dann noch mal kurz nachhaken und von den
menschen draußen das wäre sozusagen der
appell an alle wie wir uns verhalten
sollen
die menschen draußen ich meine ich kann
jeden verstehen der das leben das man
kannte vor der pandemie wieder zurück
haben möchte aber moment ist nicht die
zeit für party und
ausgehen sondern wir müssen uns jetzt
alle wieder ein stück zurück nehmen und
von der politik
würden wir uns dennoch wünschen dass
endlich mal anerkannt wird welche
leistung hier erbracht wird das auch die
der nachwuchs gefördert wird dass die
mitarbeiter die jetzt da sind einfach
gehalten werden und die flucht aus dem
beruf aufhört und so was muss ich halt
auch einfach aufgrund der verantwortung
die man trägt in diesem beruf auch am
ende des monats was der lohn angeht
widerspiegeln also das sind schon
elementare punkte die den mann daran
gehen einfach muss ja der noch
gesundheitsministerien spahn hatte
neulich mal 5000 euro als sonderzahlung
sozusagen in den raum gestellt fanden
sie das angemessen
ja die summe das ist das werden ganz
schöner bonus aber das ist ja nichts
nachhaltiges es muss nachhaltig sind
seine dauerhafte lösungen und ganz
ehrlich wenn ich scheidende
gesundheitsminister bin dann kann ich so
eine summe gern mal in den raum werfen
weil ich muss ja die entscheidung nicht
mehr treffen so was auch auszuzahlen
die eine oder andere frage würde ich
ihnen gerne noch mitgeben great reset
gender 20.30 wieviel doppelt geimpfte
deren impfung mehr als vier monate her
ist liegen denn jetzt als ungeimpft auf
den sieg station all das schon sehr
spezifische frage aber vielleicht auch
noch mal so das verhältnis von geimpft
und ungeimpft haben sie dann überblick
wie viel wie ist das ungefähr im moment
es sind schon überwiegend um geimpfte
patienten ja überwiegend um geimpft ok
also und damit eben nochmal verbundenen
der appell den sie dafür auch schon
geäußert haben sich impfen zu lassen
vielleicht noch der ein oder andere
kommentar von 08 15 kommentare pflege
ist ein job kein wochenende keine
feiertage einspringen müssen wenn ein
anderer nicht kann danke an diejenigen
die sich das antun nachdem kann man sich
in der tat nur anschließen und ja ich
möchte an der stelle wir hatten
miteinander vereinbart dass wir nicht
allzu lange sprechen sie haben heute
abend auch noch andere sachen zu tun
aber ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich dass
sie sich die zeit für uns genommen haben
und dass sie so noch einmal eindrücklich
geschildert haben wie bei ihnen die
situation ist und was jetzt aus ihrer
sicht einfach auch helfen würde wie
gesagt noch mal der hinweis auch an ihr
online oder auf ihrem online tagebuch
das ist äußerst lesenswert carsten
schmidt war das von uns vom klinikum in
saarbrücken dankeschön für die zeit- und
dankeschön dass sie sich heute abend zur
verfügung gestellt haben einen schönen
abend noch
und wir machen weiter so weit also das
beispielhafte bild von einer
intensivstation im saarland und der
angespannten lage dort das sieht aber in
anderen krankenhäusern quer durch die
republik im prinzip natürlich ähnlich
aus und damit kommen wir dann auch zu
unserem nächsten gesprächsgast er
beschäftigt sich als arzt und pandemie
beauftragte ebenfalls intensiv mit der
aktuellen misere und kann uns heute
abend von seiner arbeit am klinikum
rechts der isar in münchen berichten
einen schönen guten abend dr christoph
spinner hallo und herzlich willkommen
schönen guten abend herr wärme ja wie
ist gleiche eingangsfrage die korona
lage aktuell bei ihnen im krankenhaus
auch bei uns ist die lage sehr
angespannt nach wie vor in der
landeshauptstadt münchen gibt es nach
wie vor eine sehr hohe anzahl an corinna
neuinfektionen wir behandeln bei uns im
krankenhaus und klinikum rechts der isar
derzeit deutlich über 70 patientinnen
und patienten davon mehr als 20 auf
intensivstationen das bedeutet auch dass
mehr als jedes vierte bett aktuell durch
einen kurven patienten belegt ist und
diese ohnehin knapperen intensivbetten
fehlen ganz besonders in der akuten
medizinischen versorgung wie auch herr
schmidt aus dem saarland berichtet hat
bei der versorgung von herzinfarkten
schlaganfällen unfallpatienten und
chronisch kranken menschen
einschließlich tumorpatienten
also betten fehlen sagen sie und frage
ich sie auch noch mal nach dem
schlagwort triage wie gehen sie mit
dieser situation um müssen sie leute
schon zurückstellen müssen sie
notwendige operationen verschieben
aussetzen wie ist da die situation
als mediziner sind wir gewohnt die
knappen ressourcen zu priorisieren ich
würde nicht von dreher sprechen denn das
findet an dieser stelle so nicht statt
aber auch wir mussten beginnen wie viele
andere kliniken im bundesland bayern
aufgrund der holen die patientenzahlen
verschiebbare operationen
aufzuschieben und ins neue jahr zu
verschieben das heißt wir müssen ganz
erheblich versorgungs ressourcen der
nicht kurve bereiche info wird bereiche
umwidmen um die akute medizinische
versorgung aufrechtzuerhalten
wir hatten vorhin auch schon mit herrn
schmidt über das kleeblatt system
gesprochen
wie ist es bei ihnen nähmen sie
patienten aufgeben sie welche ab welche
erfahrungen machen sie damit
es zeigt sich ja ein ganz
offensichtlicher zusammenhang zwischen
impfquote und der anzahl an
hospitalisierten als im krankenhaus
behandelten kubik patienten und wir
sehen bei uns in bayern leider aufgrund
einer nicht ausreichend hohen impfquote
nach wie vor eine große anzahl im coop
19 patientinnen und patienten die
versorgt werden müssen in einzelnen
regionen war die lage so angespannt dass
die dortigen krankenhäuser keine
alleinige versorgung mehr gewährleisten
konnten deshalb wurden bereits mehrfach
wegen und vergangenen tagen patientinnen
und patienten aus dem zugehörigen
kleeblatt hier in bayern in andere
bundesländer verlegt und als arzt kann
ich das system nur begrüßen denn es
ermöglicht uns die regionale überlastung
durch nutzung von ressourcen zb norden
und westen der bundesrepublik zu
kompensieren indem patientinnen und
patienten dort weiter qualitativ
hochwertige intensivmedizinisch versorgt
werden können also ich merke schon die
einrichtung dieses systems stößt auf
positive resonanz sowohl bei ihnen als
auch bei herrn schmidt vorhin schon new
and the second fragt uns über youtube ab
welchem alter steigt die
wahrscheinlichkeit ein intensiv bett zu
belegen wäre eine impfpflicht ab diesem
alter dann nicht sinnvoller als eine
generelle wie es ihrer einschätzung dazu
die frage ist sehr gut und ich glaube
sie ist einer der größten irrtümer warum
sich gerade jüngere menschen nicht
impfen lassen weil sie nämlich
internalisiert also verinnerlicht haben
dass das alter das hauptrisiko schwerer
kursverläufe ist und so ist es auch
die sterblichkeit bei über 80 jährigen
ungeimpften menschen an cupid 19 zu
verstärken liegt bei fast 25 prozent das
heißt mehr als jeder vierte patient wird
in diesem alter verstärken auch wenn die
statistische sterblichkeit bei jüngeren
menschen aufgrund einer kurve infektion
sehr viel geringer ist heißt es nicht
dass es nicht im einzelfall vorkommt und
gerade bei den im moment sehr hohen
infektionen sidenten steigt damit auch
insgesamt die wahrscheinlichkeit bei
jüngeren menschen unser zuletzt jüngst
der patient auf unsere intensivstation
war 27 jahre alt und ohne jede
vorerkrankungen ich bin mir ganz sicher
dass er nicht damit gerechnet hatte
intensivmedizinisch behandelt zu werden
und gerade deshalb kommt es darauf an
auch für unsere jüngeren zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer sich impfen zu lassen denn
deco wird impfung ist die einzige
sichere und nachhaltige möglichkeit für
sich selbst und seine lieben einen
schutz vor co at 19 zu erreichen ist ja
auch da also nochmal der appell an die
impfung und an die impfbereitschaft der
leute eine besonderheit ihrer klinik ist
ja unter anderem die tatsache dass sie
auch eine station haben für menschen die
sich aus medizinischen gründen nicht
impfen lassen können vielleicht können
sie dazu noch mal ein paar worte sagen
was muss man sich darunter vorstellen
und wie können sie den patienten dann
dort helfen
die zwei jahre pandemie haben auch was
meiner sicht ganz wesentliche infektion
logische fortschritte in der therapie
erbracht wir haben nicht nur sicherer
und hocheffektiver impfstoffe die den
nachhaltigen schutz bieten es gibt ja
auch menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen können oder nicht ausreichend gut
auf die impfung ansprechen weil ihr
immunsystem nicht normal funktioniert
dazu gehören chronisch kranke menschen
ältere menschen aber insbesondere auch
menschen die medikamente zur
unterdrückung des immunsystems zum
beispiel nach einer organtransplantation
einnehmen müssen und diesen menschen
können wir die möglichkeit einer
sogenannten passiv impfung anbieten das
heißt man hat im labor abwehrstoffe
gegen saas corona virus 2 hergestellt
und verabreicht diese dann infusion oder
subkutane injektionen damit sie die
aufgabe des natürlichen immunsystems
übernehmen und so schwere verläufe um
bis zu 80 prozent reduzieren wie am
klinikum rechts der isar haben uns
deshalb entschlossen um den menschen die
schweren verläufe wirksam ersparen zu
können dass wir in unserem antikörper
therapie zentrum für diese ausgewählten
patientinnen und patienten diese
therapie ermöglichen wollen denn gerade
in einer situation besonders knapper
klinikbetten und der möglichkeit in über
80 prozent der schweren verläufe
abwehren zu können wollen wir diese
chance nicht ungenutzt lassen ja jetzt
werden bei solchen worten natürlich
wahrscheinlich auch die impfgegner
hellhörig aber da müssen wir jetzt
gleich sozusagen dem einen riegel
vorschieben denn an wen richtet sich
dieses angebot das ist ja soweit ich das
verstanden habe jetzt nicht als ersatz
angedacht für im verweigerer sondern das
richtet sich eben an einen ganz
spezifischen personenkreis
dann auf keinen fall und um das noch mal
in aller deutlichkeit zu sagen die
aktive impfung sprich die kogit impfung
ist die nachhaltigste und wirksamste
möglichkeit um schutz für sich selbst
vor provinzen zu erreichen
es gibt aber menschen die konnten sich
nicht impfen lassen oder sprechen auf
diese impfung nicht gut genug an und die
können im falle einer infektion durch
diese passive impfung also im labor
hergestellten antikörper wirksam vor
einem schweren verlauf geschützt werden
wenn sie in der ersten infektions woche
eingesetzt werden darüber hinaus sind
diese medikamente von der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur auch zum
vorsorglichen einsatz also zur
exposition prophylaxe zugelassen dies
betrifft allerdings wirklich nur
menschen die sich nicht durch aktive
schutzimpfungen schützen können die
halbwertszeit also die wirkdauer dieser
neutralisierenden antikörper ist leider
auch nur kurz deshalb muss alle vier bis
sechs wochen derzeit eine weitere
infusion verabreicht werden um den
schutz aufrechtzuerhalten und alleine
daran erkennen sie schon eine infusion
alle vier bis sechs wochen ist vom
aufwand ganz anders einzuschätzen
als die einmalige schutzimpfung und man
muss auch ganz klar sagen die
schutzimpfung bietet das günstiger
risiko nutzen verhältnis und wirkt
deutlich länger an den nach musterungen
gehen wir davon aus dass der schutz
deutlich länger also viele monate
bestehen wird muss man sich das denn
jetzt so vorstellen dass das ein angebot
ist dass sie mehr oder weniger exklusiv
in münchen machen oder gibts das an
anderen standorten auch und zumindest in
ähnlicher form
glücklicherweise gibt es dieses angebot
auch an vielen anderen standorten die
neutralisierenden antikörper stehen uns
derzeit über die bundes notfallreserve
des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums zur
verfügung damit stehen sie theoretisch
jedem krankenhaus und jedem approbierten
arzt in deutschland zur verfügung
natürlich finden sie sich im moment in
sogenannten stern apotheken das heißt
insbesondere größere kliniken haben sie
einfach und zeitnah zugriff darauf und
deswegen sollten sich betroffene
personen auch in ihren jeweiligen
regionen mit ihren ärztinnen und ärzte
in den kliniken unterhalten ob diese
möglichkeit steht ich kenne viele
kolleginnen und kollegen zu denen wir in
den vergangenen tagen kontakt hatten um
derartige antikörper therapie zentrums
angebote ebenso zu schaffen und das ist
aus meiner sichtweise infektiologe
besonders wünschenswert denn wir sollten
gerade jetzt in dieser schweren vierten
welle keine chance unversucht lassen um
den menschen alle auch die kliniken
diese schweren kurven sind verläufe zu
ersparen denn wir haben wirksame waffen
im kampf gegen die pandemie sie jetzt
alle sinnvoll gemeinsam impfung neue
therapeutika aber auch die nicht
pharmakologische interventionen also
abstand gehen alltags regel social
distance sind gemeinsam zu nutzen können
helfen diese fette welle zu brechen
dankeschön bis hierhin gesprächen gleich
weiter gerne auch noch mal der aufruf an
unser publikum mit fragen und
kommentaren an uns heran zu treten wir
leiten die dann an den fachmann weiter
und wollen jetzt noch mal sprechen über
die versorgung mit medikamenten denn das
ist ja neben dem impfen auch ein
wichtiger punkt auch eine möglichkeit
patienten zu helfen wenn es denn wirkt
und natürlich dann auch erst im
nachhinein der geschäftsführende
gesundheitsministeriums sparen der hat
sie zu diesem punkt noch mal geäußert
heute immer dann wenn wir auch nach den
einschätzungen unserer behörden des b
formen des paul-ehrlich-instituts je
nachdem welches art von medikament es
geht einen aussichtsreichen kandidaten
haben auch studienlage einen unterschied
zu machen haben wir verhandlungen
begonnen mit dem hersteller also haben
wir uns mdc wir gesichert für
deutschland so haben wir monoklonale
antikörper gesichert für deutschland so
haben wir ganz aktuell mit msd in
verhandlung das dortige medikament für
deutschland gesichert in einer ersten
vertrag 80.000 dosen natürlich reden wir
auch über folge verträge aber es war mir
erst mal wichtig dass wir erste
lieferungen noch im dezember haben so
sind wir in verhandlungen aktuell auch
mit pfizer und mit anderen über über
deren medikamente wir haben hohes
interesse an therapeutischer bei kubi 19
wir kaufen vorsorglich für unterstützen
forschung und entwicklung weil selbst
bei höchsten impfquoten ist immer auch
diejenigen gibt wo möglicherweise auch
beim ems durchbruch behandlungsbedarf
entsteht
ja also da hat der noch minister eine
ganze reihe heute vormittag von
medikamenten aufgezählt die bestellt
sind die helfen können sollen wir sind
da ihre erfahrungen aus der praxis
wir waren hier im klinikum rechts der
isar der technischen universität münchen
von der ersten stunde auch an der
klinischen erprobung von nicht
zugelassenen arzneimittel und
therapeutika im kampf gegen kuwait 19
beteiligt so wurde bei unseren teil der
mdw zulassungsstudien durchgeführt aber
auch bei anderen therapeutika wirken wir
wir mit als infektiologe kann ich mir
nur wünschen dass wir all diese
möglichkeiten ausschöpfen denn wie der
geschäftsführende
bundesgesundheitsminister auch aus
meiner sicht absolut korrekt dargestellt
hat werden wir immer menschen haben die
sich nicht impfen oder durch eine
impfung nicht schützen können die bei
denen diese schutzimpfungen auch einfach
nicht ausreichend gut wirksam sind
deshalb brauchen wir wirksame
therapeutika die große herausforderung
bei allen viruserkrankungen damit auch
bei seiner virus zwei liegt allerdings
darin dass man antiviralen substanzen
sehr sehr früh in der regel in den
ersten stunden bis der ersten woche der
therapie der infektion einsetzen muss um
überhaupt politische erfolge erzielen zu
können und selbst dann zeigt sich ein
großer unterschied der eingesetzten
substanzen
eines der hauptprobleme liegt darin wie
wir schon diskutiert hatten
neutralisierende antikörper
beispielsweise müssen ähnlich wie randy
wir als infusionen also in der klinik
oder der arzt praxis verabreicht werden
die jetzt diskutierten oralen also
tabletten therapien könnten einen
einfacheren und niederschwelligen zugang
zur therapie ermöglichen der gerade in
der primärversorgung also bei den
hausärztinnen und hausärzten eine große
und wichtige rolle spielen könnte aber
ich will an dieser stelle auch die
euphorie dämpfen bei allen
viruserkrankungen hat sich immer gezeigt
insbesondere bei den viralen
atemwegserkrankungen lässt die einflüsse
der antiviralen therapie begrenzt sind
dh die vermeidung der infektion durch
schutzimpfungen wäre der wirksamste
nachhaltigste und sicherste weg für die
menschen sich zu schützen verstehe damit
hätte sich quasi auch schon mal eine
frage erledigt denn nicht die gewesen
wäre ob denn die medikamente eine
impfung ersetzen können aber das habe
ich jetzt irgendwo otten entnommen das
ist nicht der fall
keinesfalls ich glaube dass auch für
unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer noch
einmal ganz wichtig zu betonen denn die
verhinderte cupid 19 erkrankung ergibt
sich am besten durch eine verhinderte
saß auf zwei infektionen und davor
schützen die impfungen ebenso wirksam
vor der wie vor der erkrankung selbst
therapien also antiviralen substanzen
werden immer erst zum einsatz kommen
können wenn bereits symptome aufgetreten
sind und das bedeutet auch immer dass es
nur begrenzten schutz geben wird also an
dieser stelle noch einmal klares votum
für die impfung die sicherste
möglichkeit zum schutz vor infektionen
und erkrankungen der punkt ist klar
geworden trotzdem noch einmal kurz
zurück zu den medikamenten rom über
youtube fahrt uns gibt es denn genug
davon an deutschen kliniken wie sind wir
da versorgt
derzeit stehen da die deutschen kliniken
die antiviralen optionen um
neutralisierende antikörper und randy
sie wieder zur verfügung alle anderen
antiviralen substanzen die im beitrag
thematisiert wurden sind bislang noch
nicht verfügbar das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
beabsichtigt jetzt sehr offensichtlich
diese tabletten therapie noch im
dezember zur verfügung zu stellen dafür
auch die entsprechenden
organisatorischen rahmenbedingungen zu
schaffen das ist stand heute nicht der
fall und diese medikamente würden auch
nicht in der klinik sondern in der
hausärztlichen versorgung eingesetzt
werden anders ist das auf unseren
intensivstationen hier brauchen wir
medikamente die gar nicht so sehr die
virusvermehrung selbst hemmen denn in
einem späteren erkrankung in späteren
erkrankungs stadium der kogit 19
infektionen spielt nicht mehr das virus
sondern die überreaktion des
immunsystems die entscheidende rolle und
hier werden medikamente benötigt die
überschießende immunantwort reduzieren
dafür stehen uns in den kliniken
ausreichend und genügend therapeutika
zur verfügung aber auch hier muss
einschränken gesagt werden dass sie die
sterblichkeit im die schweren verläufe
zwar verringern aber nicht so wirksam
wie eine impfung unsere eingangsfrage
der sendung war ja lässt sich die
notlage entschärfen wie fällt ihre
antwort auf diese frage aus
nur die kombination aller zur verfügung
stehenden maßnahmen wird uns helfen und
am wichtigsten das zeigt sich jetzt auch
hier in der landeshauptstadt münchen ist
es diese maßnahmen zu kombinieren das
heißt insbesondere sozialkontakte zu
reduzieren um die hohe anzahl an neu
infektionen zu reduzieren
gleichzeitig die gewonnene zeit zu
nutzen um die impfquote zu steigern die
booster quote um das andauern des
impfschutzes zu bestärken entsprechend
zu bekräftigen und gleichzeitig neue und
moderne therapie angebote in den
kliniken seines neutralisierende
antikörper oder andere medikament in der
kurve therapie zu nutzen
aber das wichtigste wäre immer noch die
infektionen zu verhindern und das kann
uns nur gelingen wenn die impfquote
nachhaltig gesteigert werden kann daran
muss gearbeitet werden und das ist auch
meine zusammenfassung um diese zeit zu
gewinnen und die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens in einzelnen regionen
zu vermeiden braucht es eine gewisse
form von reduktionen ja die sind zwar
schmerzlich aber wir werden wohl nicht
drum herum kommen das nochmal die finale
einschätzung des fachmanns danke ihnen
ganz herzlich dort der christoph spieler
war das vom klinikum rechts der isar das
war wunderbar nochmal zusammengefasst
der wunderbar im fachlichen sinne
inhaltlich ist es natürlich immer mit
dem einen oder anderen wie soll man
sagen ja mit der wehmut natürlich auch
verbunden dass wir überhaupt in einer so
ernsten situation sind aber ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich wie gesagt für die
zeit die sie sich heute für uns genommen
haben ich danke auch unserem publikum
unseren userinnen und usern auch für die
kommentare und fragen wünsche jetzt noch
einen schönen freitagabend passt auf
euch auf und ein schönes wochenende
ciao
[Musik]